o teste está me ouvindo aí pode sim
beleza bom boa noite pessoal como foi
apresentado sobre só meron só aqui de
sorocaba e falar com vocês sobre a
importância de uma geração desafios da
próxima década aproveitando falar sobre
desafio né o que que é desafio para cada
um né o que que representa um desafio
para quem tá aqui quem vê o evento hoje
pode ser simplesmente vir para cá né
sair do trabalho sair aí da universidade
vir para cá e para mim tá aqui o desafio
ainda maior né então vamos lá vou dar o
meu melhor aqui e vou estar com vocês
todo esse momento amado sobre desafio é
como será que foi né há tempos atrás
como será que ele será pegar um desafio
de décadas atrás eu posso pegar citar
meus avós que não vieram para cá para o
brasil fugindo da guerra civil espanhola
na década de 70 então olha a diferença
desafio né desafio às vezes até bateria
no celular
vou conseguir chegar no horário então
como que mudam as décadas mudanças
desafios e mudam aí as perspectivas das
pessoas bom falando de década a família
desafio não tem como não falar de
juventude e eu como estou o jovem não
tem como não falar fazer esse tema tão
importante que a juventude no brasil e
como que tá a juventude aqui no brasil
são tenho muito importante para gente
falar porque uma década ela se compõe de
pessoas que vão estar lá trabalhando e
exercendo sua melhor né então como será
que tá essa década está acontecendo no
brasil bom não sei se vocês já ouviram
falar
é sobre os neném então neném são jovens
que não trabalham nem estudam pois é tem
muito jovem assim esse dado aqui não tá
atualizado pela pesquisa do ibge 2018
mas nós temos hoje no brasil mais de 12
milhões de jovens que nem trabalha nem
estudo isso não é bom ao meu ver não bom
e parece que é muito distante da gente
né é um jovem trabalha nem estuda e não
é tão distante não porque eu passei por
isso daí eu tipo um jovem eu tenho se
tivesse experiência né e meu sonho foi
entrar numa escola técnica aqui em
sorocaba tem um e infelizmente que eu
entendo escola técnica ensino médio ou
felizmente a repetir os dois primeiros
anos e minha família decidiu que eu
tinha que morar fora do brasil e foi lá
que eu tinha primeira experiência que
mudança da minha vida e foi experiência
com estudar fora trabalhar fora e o
contato com a política pública que foi
um de despertou o interesse de trabalhar
com as pessoas entender
a entender a sociedade como ela é
organizado e a partir de um programa
chamado ajuda ao emigrante retornado seu
filho de imigrantes né então quando eu
cheguei lá eu estava no primeiro ano
trabalhando estudando um segundo ano não
tava indo muito bem e fui buscar ajuda
do governo enfim esse essa ajuda do
imigrante retornado bom e eu tava as me
tornei outra vez e comecei a estudar
mais sobre pessoas sociedade comunidade
como que como que podia participar mais
disso eu voltei pro brasil vou te passar
o cabo e tentei falar fazer algo
diferente falei pó vou participar desse
trem aí chamado política vou falar com
pessoas me relacionar ver como é que a
gente pode fazer a diferença
oi e aí uma das coisas que é que mudaram
na minha vida foi quando eu comecei
aproveitar meu tempo de lá para cá eu
devo umas qualidades aqui são algumas
imagens de coisas que eu participei
trabalhos aqui no município
representação 2015 plano municipal plano
nacional de juventude representei o
brasil fora 2017 na rússia fiz uma
capacitação também na new york
university e também participei dessa
informação sobre o desce da onu e também
beijei aproveitei meu tempo aí nos
últimos oito anos tem dedicado a vida
pública e me dedicado a conhecer essa
pessoas e as sociedades conheci 23
países e meu tempo dedicado a
compartilhar essa experiência com outros
jovens e etc e último desafio eu assumir
foi uma horta comunitária com base nos
17ls ball
e o que que eu vejo como o grande
desafio e ela posso ver como
oportunidade dessa última década que
passou não tá falando disso né então o
que que mudou de 2009 para 2019 na minha
visão uma coisa que foi discutir vocês
vão achar que é tranquilo mas para quem
tem a minha idade ou um pouco mais 31
anos foi a internet fala portão se
internet é mas por que mudou mudou a
forma que as pessoas se relacionam mudou
a forma que a gente se comunica forma
que a gente se interage com as pessoas a
importância que a gente dá para as
pessoas então vamos lá onde no brasil
são 211 milhões de habitantes sendo que
215 milhões de celulares habilitados não
tem mais celular do que pessoas nosso
país nós temos 149 milhões de pessoas
com acesso à internet né desse mobile
conectados e temos aí 130 milhões de
pessoas que usam é
e as redes para para consumir conteúdo
de consumir conteúdo diversas
plataformas a gente pode consumir
conteúdos posso um texto um vídeo é seja
ele qual for e sabe qual é o tempo que a
gente fica em média eu como eu fui fazer
essa pesquisa aqui eu fiquei assustada
pesquisa agora de fevereiro 2019 9:29
por dia falar sobrou impossível é
possível isso conta consumir no seu
celular no teu tablet então desktop não
tenho um laptop quem tem esses esses
relógios que são aí mais moderninhos né
que interagem com as redes sociais então
nós ficamos esse tempo e outra coisa que
conta para você esquece a minha netflix
conta também com isso então conta nós
estamos 9:30 todo dia consumindo
conteúdo e às vezes se relacionando mas
vamos ver como quem tá trazendo esse
tempo aqui quem tá fazendo né
é bom esse daqui eu peguei uma faixa pra
mostrar pra vocês tem que fica mais
tempo na internet né adivinha dos jovens
né então se jovem tá bom tempo na
internet acho que você não tá
trabalhando e estudando ele tá fazendo
alguma coisa aqui né na internet vamos
lá que será que ele tá fazendo aqui
vamos lá só que é um geral tá peguei o
jovem como exemplo então nós temos aqui
são a as principais buscas do google 18
vamos lá facebook pessoas né se
relacionam procure informações sobre
tempo consome conteúdo insumo que é o
youtube enfim tem vários aqui né nós
temos aqui até elas compram muito né
mercadolivre aqui enfim bom vamos lá
sabe que eu não se abre a tua a tua
página e você digita direto o site que
você está acostumado você não faz a
busca você coloca direto é esse
resultado aqui então nós temos o google
de novo né google.br o google.com se tem
youtube também stream facebook globo tal
oi livre tem um interessante que o
chamado entretenimento o que que os
jovens deve tá usando bastante aqui né
mas vamos lá e o que que tá sendo mais
buscado no youtube será que você não
coisa positiva
ou será que a busca significasse aquele
com tudo que nos interessa
eu gosto muito nem né mas eu falei eu só
alguns exemplos aqui o que que nós
estamos buscando falo nosso porque eu
também faço parte dessa dessa geração
aqui vamo lá bom mc música filme música
novamente vamos lá tem um galinha
pintadinha olha quem está consumindo
quem será consumido seus pais né tabela
das crianças estão sendo induzidas a
linha um conteúdo né vamos lá peppa que
deve ser peppa pig porque pega a palavra
primeira né então vamos lá aí tem app
partir de aqui embaixo outono tenta no
trem tópicos aqui duas vezes
é muito interessante felipe neto
influências né que surgiram aí
tá bom aí eu falei bom sabe o exemplo né
como que as redes estão afetando a minha
vida hoje eu peguei e fiz um print da
minha tela que sou bem interessante todo
mundo que tem o tamanho essa pode fazer
eu recebi vou na play aqui preciso
começa um dele eu recebi um milhão 262
mil mensagens em vez 150 mil mensagens
eu preciso que eu preciso que é verdade
né teve aqui não tô vendo nenhum é um
print da minha tela né o vídeo que eu
fiz a tela então vejam gente eu recebi
mais um milhão de mensagens eu retornei
um pouco mais aqui que dez porcento será
que esse conteúdo não só que eu tô
consumindo de livre espontânea vontade
ali né que eu vou na tela lá e coloca a
busca será que ele é bom e está vindo
para mim será que é de mim de meu
interesse
de que forma que me relacionando esses
grupos que nós participamos meu tempo
como que eu tô dedicando para isso
porque isso aqui são pessoas claro tem
grupo ali mas em grande maioria são
pessoas como tudo que no meu tempo um
pouquinho mais dois por cento só tão
próximo exemplo bom e falando sobre
desafio o que que nós temos aí né nessa
década pra gente poder aí trazer e a
gente vê o indicador e fala para legal
então só trouxe um monte de problema
aqui o que que é bom para nossa você
sabe essa que é pirâmide etária do
brasil então nós temos a próxima década
passar aqui um burro etário a gente vai
estar aqui na década onde nós teremos a
maior quantidade e melhor assim espero
mão de obra para o brasil avançar e que
forma esses jovens eles vão subir nessa
pirâmide aqui não na próxima década eles
vão tá na principal cadeia produtiva no
caso eles vão empreender eles vão tá
o público a se inscreveu eles vão tá
trabalhando de organizações restrições
mas será que estão preparados para isso
será que nós estamos preocupados em
buscar um setor e um ambiente adequado
para eles
e essa desafio que eu vejo que o brasil
bom fazer um indicadores aí indicadores
internacionais essa é a última a última
publicação do banco mundial é ele fala
sobre as habilidades muito se fala sobre
habilidades do futuro fala sobre
habilidades necessárias do amanhã e as
habilidades são necessárias para os
desafios né a importância dessa geração
que vem aí e eu falei até agora aqui
sobre se relacionar com pessoas entender
sociedades e olha que interessante se
não sabe tá falando banco mundial uma
olha resolução de problemas perplexos
primeira habilidade que foi citada
segunda habilidade pensamento crítico
a terceira criatividade quando comecei
ali eu fiz o produção aqui né como
comecei a ler esse artigo eu achei que
ia tá lá três línguas é entender de
programação olha que interessante não
gestão de pessoas
a coordenação com os outros habilidade
de se relacionar de saber se doar tem
empatia inteligência emocional saber que
aquilo não é teu saber que você pode
colaborar mas é você ter compaixão é
diferente de você é absorver aquilo que
não tem aquela carga emocional
julgamento e tomada de decisões fala que
interessante ter transparência
orientação do serviço saber de mandar
não se centralizador acabar com essa
coisa ele que as coisas outras pessoas
são formadoras de todas as decisões
a negociação
e flexibilidade cognitiva é você numa
chácara dona da verdade e olha como que
interessante isso vem de encontro para
entender que as habilidades futuro elas
têm uma palavra incomum que eu falei
várias vezes aqui que é as pessoas
olá pessoal saber se relacionar deus
quem tá fazendo aqui tá se relacionando
está sendo informação sabe viver em
sociedade e uma coisa que é muito
interessante eu peguei essa pesquisa
aqui por causa uma publicação da onu
também profissionais do futuro deve
aprender empatia e julgamento crítico
definir o banco mundial então isso vai
essas habilidades eu não sei cada vez
mais requisitadas dentro do ambiente da
próxima década
o e tendo isso como como um indicador
porque não pensar nas pessoas né não
pensar de forma que não pode melhorar o
ambiente nós estamos e toda vez que eu
tô com esses jovens dando palestras ou
de encontro nesse bate-papo que eu que
eu tenho feito muitos jovens vem
conversar comigo e perguntam vocês eu
queria saber um pouco mais sobre isso
com ninguém te desenvolve e como que ele
pode participar saber mais porque isso
eu aprendi na universidade as
universidades hoje tem dificuldade de
descobrir os cursos que elas vão ofertar
na próxima década da mentira é isso é
muito difícil a gente saber então quais
essas habilidades são interessantes que
são de relacionamento e eu busco contar
uma história para ele tentar sintetizar
e que é muito relacionada à questão de
propósito que é o que eu acredito muito
quando a gente se encontra umas
propósito a gente tem um caminho para
traçar e certa vez estava conversando a
minha nunca me encontrei um jovem
talento uma pedra e p
e ele assim jovem que você tá fazendo tá
lendo uma pedra beleza continua aí
cheguei no outro jovem encontrei outro
jovem falou que está fazendo jovem
totalizando essa pedra aqui mas fala
para ele não vou construir um templo que
é para minha comunidade foi ó que legal
é bem mais um pouco voltei outro jovem
talento uma pedra e perguntei para ele
que você tá fazendo ele levantou e falou
para mim eu tô construindo nosso futuro
e é isso esse sentimento eu quero passar
para vocês independente da habilidade
que você tenha você tem que ter a tua
vocação essa é uma chamada que não tem
que fazer para ser adulto e assumir as
nossas responsabilidades do nosso amanhã
e é isso que eu queria trazer para vocês
e compartilhar muito obrigado
e aí